hi Ivan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers friend who asks
I'm a sales manager for a fairly large
company the company I'm working with has
taken an OP in sales due to
mismanagement and I'm the one who has to
get the horse out of the swamp
I need materials on sales management and
motivation material for my reps please
free to assist Thank You Fred
so Fred when you did with the sales team
you want to make sure that you're
setting them up for success and right
from the start what I would encourage
you to do is first start with a good
training program so you need to make
sure you know personally what works in
this business so I'm not sure what
you're selling but tops is some of your
best sales right so hopefully you've
also gone through the process of selling
this product or service before and you
need to know what works so you got to
know what script to use you have to know
people should be going through
connectors or forming partnerships or if
it's cold calling or whatever the
strategies are that works you want to
make sure you know that and you're
effectively training that into your team
when you have new guys who are coming on
and are nervous and they're not trained
properly it's big trainer so you have to
make sure you have the training in place
to make them effective the second thing
I'll try to encourage you to do is feed
them leads a lot of new sales people
when I'm coming into a position are
expected to just start producing sales
leads and that's really tough especially
if the salesperson hasn't had much
experience in your industry they may be
great at sales but it could take them
time to get started and you don't want
to have them lose too much confidence so
as much as possible try to feed them
sales leads if you if you're collecting
leads from your website or from any
advertising try to pass those on to your
sales people so it's not all cold
introductions and they get their feet
wet is a couple of warm leads for them
to follow up on and it gives it a little
more confidence to continue in my first
software company
we hired a whole bunch of
International distributors to work with
than ever our partners and to get them
started we always fed them the leads
that we got from those different
countries so they were expected to go
out and generate their own leads and
close sales but we also helped them
whenever new leads came in because we
wanted to see them achieve success gain
confidence know that hey we can actually
sell this and want to continue promoting
our product so it's most impossible if
you can try to feed your salespeople
some leads the third thing I want to
recommend is I don't know what your
compensation model looks like
but obviously you want out a couple
early skewed towards making sales and
earning the Commission on it there's a
margin to motivate and there's an
incentive to go and want to sell but at
the beginning that can be really
discouraging if they're not making any
money so you think the salesperson you
know has good potential I would
definitely encourage you to house and
kind of draw at the beginning to make
sure they're still making an income it's
not a super comfortable income but
they're making money they're able to get
by and sport themselves while they're
learning how to sell your product or
service because you should people can't
step in and right away start selling
there was a ramp up period and if
they're not making any money then
they're gonna start looking for other
opportunities that they don't start
seeing immediate results so I hope that
helps friend if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up I'd also love
to hear your thoughts and feedback if
you want to leave a comment below the
video and stay tuned for the next
episode
you